كانت هناك بعض التبادلات كما
ذكرت بالفعل ولكن مرت
عدة أسابيع ولم يتم
إطلاق سراح الرهائن، لماذا تعتقد أن هذا هو سبب
توقف الأمر؟ لدي شعور
بأن ناتان يريد استمرار الحرب
لأنه يريد ذلك  كسب
الحرب لكنه لا يستطيع الاستمرار في الحرب
وإخراج الرهائن، فهو
يحتاج إلى الاستمرار في وقف إطلاق النار
ثم إخراجهم ويحتاج إلى
إخراجهم الآن في أسرع وقت
ممكن لأن 88 يومًا  هل أنت
قلق من أن رئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو يعطي الأولوية لكسب
الحرب على إعادة الرهائن إلى الوطن؟ لدي
شعور بأن هذا هو سبب
استمرار الحروب، فهو يريد الفوز في الحرب ولكن هل
تعتقد أنه يعطي الأولوية لذلك على
إعادة الرهائن إلى الوطن؟  أنا لست
سياسيًا وهناك أشياء لا
أفهمها ولكني أعلم أنه
يجب أن يكون هناك وقف لإطلاق النار حتى
يخرجوا وليس هناك
بحار